it's great to be back from vacation and
i will talk about
what i did on the bonus show but we have
to jump right into it we learned at the
start of this weekend that supreme court
justice ruth bader ginsburg
passed away at the age of 87 and this is
simultaneously
set off a nationwide
really a global mourning period for one
of the
premier progressive jurists a truly
remarkable legal mind whose legal acumen
was surpassed maybe only by her wit
and sense of humor and it has set off a
political firestorm
immediately refreshing the battle
from the last year of barack obama's
presidency
over the nomination of merrick garland
then to replace
the late supreme court justice antonin
scalia that was a nomination remember
which republicans led by mitch mcconnell
successfully blocked and we're going to
be talking about
all of it now first of all is the
personal i'm going to focus on the
political
but ruth bader ginsburg's personal story
is an incredible one
born in brooklyn at a time when the
legal world
was a big uphill battle not just for
women but for jewish women
a tiny woman barely five feet tall
ultimately becoming the second woman
ever to be on the supreme court
after sandra day o'connor's retirement
in 2006
rbg was the only woman on the supreme
court a cultural icon well into her 80s
really a rock star in the political in
the social in the cultural world there's
no way to say all of the things that
could be said
about ruth bader ginsburg now there is a
criticism
that she should have retired when she
was
say 82 years old already with some
health problems
to ensure that barack obama
would have gotten a clean chance to
choose her replacement
to preempt the situation we now see
and that is a fair criticism and it's in
the past
and there's nothing we can do about it
now and so what is the story now well
the story
now is there are 45-ish days remaining
maybe 45 exactly until an election
in which donald trump might lose and
donald trump and republicans most
republicans have shown that they are
committed to filling this seat and
filling it as soon as possible
we're going to talk about who might opt
out of that
but it is of course a huge double
standard in 2016
when barack obama was in his last year
republicans said let the people have a
say
let the people vote before we fill this
seat and indeed they won on that
they held the seat they refused to give
barack obama's nominee merrick garland
confirmation hearings and ultimately
donald trump filled that seat a year
later with neil gorsuch to replace
antonin scalia and now seemingly the
same situation
republicans are saying we have a
constitutional duty to fill this seat
without delay
and they are going to try now mitch
mcconnell's explanation is well
it's not really the same situation
because back in 2016
it was opposite parties in the senate
and white house
it was barack obama a democrat and
republicans controlling the senate
it's different now because it's
republicans
controlling the senate with a republican
president
that is their argument it's a ridiculous
argument
it is a double standard but it doesn't
matter what matters is are they going to
be able to do it
and we're going to talk about that in a
moment the legacy of ruth bader ginsburg
is one that will be studied hopefully
for a very long time
it's an inspirational story not just
to young women about someone who really
uh pushed the boundaries of what society
uh considered to be the appropriate or
or or
valid roles of women in society really
uh an extraordinary woman an
extraordinary career
and again a a cultural and legal
icon well into her 80s
we will miss her her legacy and
now the question is what will become of
that seat and that's what we're going to
talk about next we'll talk about process
and we'll talk about political
implications one of our sponsors today
is surf
shark which is a premium vpn service
they're giving my audience
83 off a two-year plan plus
three extra months for free which all
comes out to about two bucks a month and
if you're not already using a vpn
service you really are opening yourself
up to
internet service providers logging and
selling your internet history
tech companies tracking what you do
online even government surveillance
surfshark is a vpn that helps protect
you from
all of those things by hiding your ip
address when you're browsing online
comes with a bunch of other great
features it's a company you can actually
trust with your privacy and you can
install surfsharkvpn
on unlimited devices they never keep
logs of your internet activity
and you can even use it to stream shows
and movies that are only available
in other countries surf shark is giving
my audience
83 off a two-year plan plus
three extra month free so that comes out
to just about two dollars a month which
is
almost nothing relative to the peace of
mind you will have
while browsing online just go to
surfshark.deals
pacman i've put the link underneath this
video and make sure to use the coupon
code pacman